Trump is getting.
We were just talking about this
a few moments ago.
Kristen Holmes was in Waco, Texas.
We all know what Waco means.
He's kicking off this campaign
rally there
during the 30th anniversary
of the deadly standoff
there between
federal agents and the Branch Davidians.
That separatist group
where we had
that clash
that resulted in so much violence.
We heard from the Trump campaign on this.
They're telling CNN it's
just a coincidence
that it's happening this weekend.
You guys buy that
No.
Like John Avlon
wants to just rip this one apart.
Jim Acosta, I'm going to appreciate that.
Look,
I tried to ask that question honestly.
But it doesn't seem to me
that this just does not pass.
So, look, I look at it and there's a lot
that happens at work
that has nothing to do with the branch
division.
Davidian cult compound siege.
But it's the 30th anniversary.
Trump has made very few rallies.
It's not like
he's been barnstorming the country
and Waco was the next logical step on the
on the tour
in a really red state
that he's going to have to win
if he's going to win. Yeah.
So and just to remind people,
I mean,
I wrote a book called Wingnuts,
you know, a couple of years ago
that dealt with extremism
in American politics
and the Branch Davidian compound
siege and the aftermath.
And let's not forget, there were 20 ATF
agents killed
or wounded in that seat in the aftermath,
as well as members
of the cult in question
and children
who'd been physically
and sexually abused in that cult.
This took on a major icon of iconography
for the anti-government
far right militia movement in America.
This is a major event.
This is not something
that's just off to the side that people
forget about in that strain
of a far right anti-government movement,
you know, crested to some respect
after January six.
So it's the 30th anniversary.
We need to hear what Trump says,
whether they're obvious
dog whistles or less obvious
dog whistles to this.
The town of Waco
is defined by a lot more than this,
but this choice
speaks loud and clear
about what he sees as his base
and the really way
it makes a mockery of any claim
for Republicans
to represent law and order
under his policies.
Right.
And I can't imagine, Margaret,
that when they said, oh,
maybe we should have the rally in Waco,
that there wasn't anybody
in his circle on his staff
anywhere who said, oh,
wait a minute,
you know,
Waco, Texas, didn't
they have that thing
with the Branch Davidian?
Maybe we shouldn't do that.
And they went ahead with this anyway.
I mean,
when you
have this
after what took place on January six,
after what happened in Charlottesville,
the way Trump reacted to that, very fine
people on both side.
I mean, there just seems to be this,
you know, he likes to go back
and push the those buttons. It seems
Yeah.
No, I think it's based on
if we didn't know anything
about it, Donald Trump,
this or 20, 15,
maybe we could give him
the benefit of the doubt.
But this is somebody who after
in particular,
after January six
and after the almost 1000 prosecutions,
indictments around that act and around
all of the evidence that has come out
since then
about Trump's
direct involvement and agitation and and
movement towards violence and frankly,
you know, pushing people towards
violent what became a very violent
and dangerous day at the Capitol.
If he's not going to Waco
and I think it's very safe for all of us
to just make this jump.
He didn't go to Waco because a former US
president Republican president has
his ranch there.
Yeah, this isn't about
this is not about George W Bush.
This is very clearly Chapel Ranch.
This is very clearly about About him
making a statement against the backdrop
of the people who he knows
are the most ardent supporters of him.
That's right. Right.
And it comes on the heels
of all these reports
about how
the previous events
that he's had so far in this cycle
been sort of lackluster.
And, you know,
you could just see the gears
turning there inside the Trump team
thinking they could
stoke flames once again. I just
you know, and I think
thinking that the Israelis
have been lackluster
or that they will continue to be.
Is there really
something that all of us
do at our own peril? As observers here?
Because Donald Trump is really back.
I mean, he's back and he's stirring up
all of the forces,
I think, that are
the least productive forces
in our politics.
What I think so
significant is that he's identifying
this strain of the far right as his base,
that something that needs to be inflamed.
And in the context of the comments
he's made around this possible indictment
where he's again fanning these flames.
Those two things need to be understood
in relationship to each other,
that that's the larger danger
right Exactly.
And you can't ignore the danger.
I mean, ignoring
it doesn't make it go away.
And John and Margaret,
let me ask you, the Manhattan grand
jury investigating
Trump in the Stormy Daniels
case is expected to resume on Monday.
Trump said
he expected to be arrested
this past week.
That obviously never happened.
He also warned of potential death
and destruction if he's charged
but in the end, indictment,
weak was a lot
like Infrastructure Week for Trump, but
it just didn't happen.
You know
how much of this was
how much of this was Trump
trying to just get everybody
dialed up on this thing and in his base
among his supporters?
I mean, look,
what we understand in hindsight,
having actually seen that
the grand jury wasn't
even going to convene on Wednesday.
I mean, this was I mean, that
that came out later.
But, you know, there
Trump is very clearly trying to rile up
support from his base
and try to own the narrative
and try to try to make this
about an opportunity to support him,
to fundraise off of, frankly,
to make him the victim.
And and I think, you know,
at our own peril
in the media,
we we fall for it sometimes.
But but it's not that benign, right?
I mean, he's doing it through threat.
He's not playing the rap
and trying to rile up his base on that.
And look, take a big step back.
No one
should cheerlead
the indictment of an ex-president,
but the political implications of this
should be something that
don't matter nearly
as much as simply following the law.
The principle of equal justice
under the law
needs to trump,
no pun intended, everything
resembling partizan politics
and his attempts
to play the rap
through threats
or fear,
or that, oh,
this will benefit me politically or may
it might doesn't matter
you apply the law without fear or favor.
That's that's what
democratic republics do.
And that's what we
need to do as a country.